[Music]
so afghanistan is marking its 102nd
anniversary of independence on thursday
but it's also coming to terms with the
return to life under taliban rule in the
city of izadabad at least two people
were killed at an independence day rally
and in host taliban fighters were
enforcing a curfew to stop protests at
kabul airport children were hoisted
above crowds as people tried to flee the
uk says it's unable to evacuate children
who are unaccompanied president joe
biden says u.s forces could stay on in
afghanistan until all american citizens
are out
even if that means missing his august
the 31st deadline for troops to leave
we'll get more on that in a moment but
first let's go to charlotte bellows
who's live for us in a couple and so
charlotte we have this independence day
coming just uh days after the taliban
took control of the country and we've
seen these these pockets of protests and
violence
yeah there have there have been a few
incidents the biggest one happening in
assad about in kuna where
it's unclear really what has happened we
know two people have been killed and
eight people have been injured but it's
unclear how they were killed and injured
from residents accounts they say that
somebody actually stabbed a taliban
fighter and in the chaos the taliban
started shooting and then there was a
stampede and now we have two people
killed and eight injured there was also
a similar incident in jalalabad just
east of kabul where a crowd gathered and
two people were shot
by the taliban there and then in kabul
uh it's been relatively quiet actually i
mean i've been here during independence
days in the past and usually
the traffic is very heavy people have
the republic flag which is the green red
and black flag out of their cars
soldiers are waving the flags people are
singing there's loud music there's
really very little of that today there's
been isolated
crowds moving waving the flag and that
has been allowed by the taliban
there has been some isolated protests
where people have been chanting
the flag is my identity it follows
protests yesterday in in other parts of
afghanistan predominantly in the east
where people very upset that the taliban
has taken down the republic flag in many
places and raised instead their own flag
and so people are resisting that and
really pushing back uh and the taliban
have been allowing that for for the most
part uh in nangarhar for example the
governor there saying it's fine you
could you can carry on and use the flag
and celebrate like you normally would
all right so quietish around the city
what about the airport we've been seeing
chaotic scenes there
yeah that's been happening since
essentially since president ghani fled
on sunday afternoon people panicked and
have started flooding the airport then
these evacuation flights picked up
various countries sending in their
military planes and and thousands upon
thousands of afghans just making a run
for the airport trying to get on some of
these evacuation flights the taliban are
securing the perimeter at the moment and
the main problem is
in their crowd control technique which
is predominantly shoot in the air and
whip people to push them back and the
problem with that is is that many of
these people do actually have valid
documents and are entitled to get on
some of these evacuation flights but
they're having a hard time
getting past essentially this taliban
front line to get to their flights and a
lot of people just too scared really and
going home other people sleeping around
the airport so still a lot of chaos uh
anarchy as as people try to get on them
and the taliban try to push them back
the taliban
also admitting that since sunday 12
people have died in kabul
nato also confirming that number and i
spent some time in a hospital yesterday
and can confirm that that some of those
deaths did actually come from the
airport and its perimeter
all right charlotte we'll leave it there
for the moment uh that's the latest in
kabul charlotte villas reporting there
let's bring our guests now talent
massoud he's a strategic affairs analyst
and joins us from islamabad uh
so this timing of independence dave so
soon after the taliban takeover was
always likely to be something of a flash
point do you think it's it's something
that's likely to develop
well it could uh because uh you know
there are a lot of people in the cities
and especially in kabul and other places
uh where they are very disheartened
by the takeover of taliban and also that
they would never like
them to impose their rule on them so i
think they will find an opportunity to
sort of present and i think it could
take a turn if the taliban also try to
be very harsh on them so i think it's a
very difficult situation at government
in afghanistan because there are in the
cities of people who just resent the
rule
of the taliban but at the same time the
taliban have been able to impose their
will on them
because of the fact that they had a
rural support and also the military
completely collapsed the iran military
against them so i think at the moment
the ones will have to somehow the other
bear them and
the taliban leadership will also have to
modulate their behavior
in order to understand
the
present situation yeah what about this
this resistance movement in in jan shear
province we have ahmad massoud calling
for support he was writing in an opinion
piece of the washington post indeed do
you think he's likely to get that kind
of support that he needs
well i think that
you know he is trying to resist but i
doubt very much uh if that would be
successful and i think the taliban will
launch an attack on them
yeah but i think he's trying to show
that he's still one of those uh who have
been able to resist the taliban
supremacy
but it's only a matter of time then i
think the taliban will be able to
overwhelm it
because
it's very difficult to have this pocket
of resistance
in a place where practically the whole
of afghanistan is under their country
so how looking ahead perhaps to the
medium term how do you see it once these
evacuations are through at the airport
and that kind of settles down
might the international community
changed their tune on their at the
moment this apparent acceptance of
taliban rule
yeah i agree with you that there will be
a level of acceptance because there is
no other alternative
and the fact that the previous
government was also extremely corrupt
and inefficient and did not have the
support of the rural
areas at least and also within the
cities they had limited support of a
certain elite so i think considering all
that they think that there is no other
alternative but to sort of modulate or
improve the behavior
of the taliban leadership so that and
they are more and
you know sort of behave and conduct
themselves in the more civilized
that is the only thing i think and then
obviously they have the springs that
they could pull because
the
afghanistan is at the moment
it is facing a serious financial crisis
at the same time
you know it also is facing a diplomatic
price
so i think in considering all that
the taliban leadership is
will have to show some flexibility as
well so there will be flexibility on
both sides and i think there will be
some part of an arrangement and you
would see and i would agree with you
that over some uh over a few weeks you
will find that
there will be
uh better coexistence between the west
and how critical is it for the survival
of this or the success i should say of
taliban rule that they
are they include in their government
members of the previous government
well that would be helpful but i think
more than the previous government
because you know the members of the
previous government they're also very
corrupt and
they have a legacy here you know
following them so i i would say that it
would have been much better if they
would have chosen people who have a
reputation but have not it had not been
soiled
over a period of time
and and they should take much younger
people
in the cabinet rather than those old
people
who have uh served practically every
regime
and have brought a bad name to it
all right appreciate that thanks very
much indeed for speaking to us sir
thanks a lot thank you